зруйнований момент сімдесятих корот
має
Манчестер
об'єднані в
реабілітація з ним
троянда
кількість безробітних дуже мала
як ніколи
60 відсотків 6 відсотків безробіття
це добре, хоча
при цьому кількість відкритих
встановлено на рекордному рівні
водії вантажівки офіціанти
медсестра аеропорту
інженерів
техніків від некваліфікованих до
університетські дипломи Європі потрібні
Тому ми повинні бути набагато сильнішими
інвестування в освіту та навчання
ми хочемо тісно співпрацювати з компанією
працювати разом, тому що ви знаєте, що я
найкраще, які професіонали ви сьогодні
а й які кваліфіковані працівники їм потрібні
потрібен завтра, і нам потрібен цей
потребує набагато кращого примирення
з цілями та бажаннями
самі шукачі роботи за свої
кар'єрний шлях у нас такий чудовий
великі інструменти sf, але нам потрібні
з іншого боку також структура
що ці кошти дійсно ефективні
можна використовувати і другий
також важливо, щоб ми були цільовими
залучати фахівців з-за кордону
я роблю бізнес тут і в Європі
почати ріст і тому є a
важливий крок вашої кваліфікації
вони можуть робити те, що ці люди належать їм
кваліфікація в європі краще і
швидше визнати, що це те
можливість зробити європу привабливішою
для всіх, хто щось може і хто є
хочуть зробити свій внесок і тому пропонують
Я перед своєю величезною темою, що можна
не торгуйте тут я пропоную
що ми рік 20 23 до європейського
рік навчання та підвищення кваліфікації
давайте зосередимося на цьому
встановіть, що це правильний зараз
крок
[Оплески]